apple has finally announced their april
20th event
and based on all of the different puzzle
pieces that have
just come together i am almost 100
sure that we'll be getting a new 24-inch
imac
from apple revealed at the event in just
a few days
now i know it's technically not
confirmed until it happens
but i'm going to go ahead and just call
it we
will be seeing an imac next week and if
i'm wrong
you guys can come back to this video
into this channel and make fun of me
call me names or whatever you want to do
but trust me
there are so many different things that
just perfectly aligned
yesterday morning so in this video i'm
gonna show you guys how everything comes
together
for a new imac release next week and
then i'm gonna share my thoughts on
which features you should expect
as well as the other products you should
be expecting from the apple event
so let's get right into it way back last
year we started to see leaks and rumors
from various sources
that claim that we'd be seeing a new 23
or 24 inch imac
either at the end of 2020 or the
beginning of 2021
now the interesting part is that they
only mentioned the smaller imac
and not the 27 inch model and that
totally makes sense because back in
august
apple updated the 27 inch but they
basically left the 21 and a half inch
model
alone which signaled that the 24-inch
imac
would be coming first with the fresh
redesign and apple silicon chips
now moving on in october it was reported
that apple was working on a redesigned
imac
with a new chip and an apple designed
discreet
gpu and they mentioned that it's set to
ship in the first half of 2021.
now i personally believe that they were
referring to the larger 27-inch imac
being replaced by that new model because
in my opinion
the smaller one does not need discrete
graphics
apple for sure is going to want to save
that for the more expensive
larger model which i think is coming
later in the year
because apple needs time to work on the
dedicated gpu
then just two months ago john prosser
revealed a
huge and surprising leak the 2021 imac
may come in five different colors
which hasn't happened since the original
imac
then last month jon went on to say that
the new imac
is basically ready and could launch at
any time
and after that things started to get
very interesting
on march 17th an apple silicon imac
leaked
within an xcode crash log and apple even
confirmed it
which shows that these new imac models
are operational
and apple is currently testing them and
then on march 19th
apple officially discontinued the
27-inch imac pro
and the very next day they discontinued
the larger storage models of the 21.5
inch imac
and this sort of stuff only usually
happens
before a big launch of a new product and
then
a couple of days later we had a massive
leak
within the beta code of macos big sur
11.3
pointing to two brand new unreleased
imac models
now this is extremely important because
i don't know if you know this or not
but just a couple of weeks before apple
revealed the m1 max last year
the exact same thing happened mac os
beta code
revealed three unreleased macs which of
course ended up being the m1 macbook air
the macbook pro and mac mini and
literally just yesterday morning
apple seeded the latest beta version of
big sur 11.3 to developers
pointing to this software releasing very
soon and this is very likely because
last week
tim cook mentioned that ios 14.5 is
coming
in just a few weeks and as we already
know
apple usually releases software for
their various platforms at the same time
and it's often on the same day that
apple's new products are available to
order
and what makes this even better is that
the upcoming ipad pros
a14x chip leaked in ios 14.5 beta
as well as a new 120 hertz apple tv
feature
in tv os 14.5 beta but i'll get into
those other products
after all the imac stuff so just the
fact that we're expecting mac os big sur
11.3 very soon
and those two imac models were leaked
within that version of mac os
it's already becoming pretty convincing
that we should be getting the new imacs
this month
but the weird part is that there are two
leaked mac identifiers
so the question is do those two models
point to two different models of the
24-inch imac
or do they point to both the small and
the large imac launching at the same
time
well in my opinion i think that we're
just getting the 24-inch imac
and the two identifiers simply point to
two
different motherboards which we've seen
in the past with apple's previous max
but now i want to get into by far the
most important puzzle piece that is
making me
basically confirm that the imac is
coming at next week's event
love to dream one of the most reliable
apple leakers out there
posted a tweet showing rainbow colors
and an imac
basically confirming what john prosser
said about the five new colors for the
24 inch imac
in fact he even replied with a thumbs up
to john's original tweet so it seems
like the new imac colors are happening
for sure and just a few weeks ago we
started to get some leaks showing that
apple was going to release
some new spring themed case colors for
the iphone 12
and some of them ironically look exactly
like the imac color leak
from john prosser and then just
yesterday more of those cases
leaked like the dark purple looking
amethyst case
and apparently they're launching this
month and on top of that
max wineback another leaker actually
said that we should be seeing new
spring-colored apple watch bands as well
and now let's finally get into the
bombshell that wraps all of this
up apple's event invitation is titled
spring
loaded basically pointing to a couple of
different things
first off it means that the event is
going to be packed with new
announcements and products
making the imac release much more likely
on top of that
the invite shows a bunch of spring
themed colors
literally matching up to the spring
cases that were leaked
as well as some of the imac colors and
we know for sure that this event is
spring themed
because of the augmented reality image
that apple created
showing off all of the colors and greg
joswiak
even tweeted this new morphing logo
outside within apple park right next to
a bunch of blooming trees
so based on that if apple is gonna be
releasing a redesigned imac with a bunch
of new colors
the absolute best time would be to
release it
alongside the rest of the spring themed
iphone cases
apple watch bands and everything else
and since the event is spring themed
it makes the most sense to release all
of that
at the event including the new imac and
just to add a bit more confirmation to
the new imac releasing next week
macromers posted a couple of days ago
that the 21.5 inch imac
just hit an all-time low price of just
950 dollars and if you know anything
about how sales on apple products go
apple has to approve the sale before
retailers can give
discount prices so there's a good chance
that apple is getting rid of
inventory before the new imac is
revealed
especially since they already
discontinued the larger storage models
last month so based on all of those
puzzle pieces coming together
including the leaked apple silicon imac
in the xcode
crash log the leaked imac identifiers
that just so happen to be
in the mac os big sur 11.3 version
that's releasing very soon
and everything else i am officially
calling it
the 24 inch imac is coming at apple's
april event now with that said i think
it's going to look almost
exactly like john prosser's renders or
these ones from ian's elbow on twitter
which look
very clean and on top of that i believe
that there are two different
options that could happen in terms of
the apple silicon chip
either they are just releasing the base
model for around eleven hundred dollars
with the same exact m1 chip that we
already have in the other max
or they're gonna give us an upgrade
option with
the 12 core m1x chip but that doesn't
seem that likely
and it seems a bit hard to believe
because we're not expecting the m1x
macbook pros
until later this year but i guess we're
just gonna have to wait and see
now don't expect user upgradable ram
because that will 100
not happen on this imac it's gonna be
soldered on
but other than that the design change
will be the best part
about the new imac now as far as the
other products that we should expect to
get released
at the event we're basically 100 sure
that we're getting
new ipad pro models with the a14x chip
uncle pan also agreed with this saying
that we should expect the ipad pro
and the air tags bluetooth trackers so
you should expect those to come as well
we did also get a leak of the new ipad
pro models
as well as an ipad mini which
unfortunately did not get a redesign
so the new mini should be coming at the
event as well
simply getting a chip upgrade to the a14
chip
and probably not much else there was
also a leaked sticker
which seems to be a new magic keyboard
case for the ipad pro
so i think that we can 100 expect that
to be released at the event as well now
on top of that there's actually a pretty
good chance that we're going to be
getting a new
apple tv at the event but it's probably
50 50 because of a couple of different
reasons
first off leaked code was found in the
last tv os beta version
pointing to a new apple tv model with
120 hertz refresh rate support
and as we know that version of tvos is
coming within the next couple of weeks
on top of that we're expecting the apple
tv to get the a14x chip
which was leaked within the ios 14 beta
code
so there's a chance that apple is gonna
announce and show off this chip
and then put it into the ipad pro and
the apple tv at the same time the only
issue is that a couple of months ago the
verifier reported that the apple tv 6
is actually coming in the fourth quarter
of this year
so i guess we'll just have to wait and
see what happens at the event there's
also a chance that we'll be getting new
airpods
which uncle pan believes are coming at
the event
but there are some other leakers and
reporters who say that they're going to
be getting
delayed so we're really not sure so
there you guys go
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you totally disagree with my
speculations
on the imac coming next week go ahead
and let me know down below
but if you're excited for all those
apple products click the circle above
because we're going to be getting our
hands on
all of them so thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video